and sometimes when i be telling these
stories
i'll be crying but i'll be crying from
the inside
you never see a tear drop but for this
i've been crying all my life
i've been crying all my life but god's
been crying with me
i've been crying all my life
all right david david where'd you grow
up where are you from
i'm originally from san francisco
and uh as i was growing up
as a still as a teenager a little boy
my mom moved to pasadena
and uh but but as a kid
i was raised in pasadena but i didn't
know nothing but pastor dean i didn't
know
if i go too far where i am i'm lost
so i caught a bus one day and this bus
landed me a skid row
on 5th and broadway and it was live
in 1975 it was live
uh bars open 24 hours a day
people walking back and forth it's a
whole bunch of traffic a whole bunch of
activity going on and you know what age
were you in this
what age were you oh 17
yes and i lived here uh instead bro
from 17 and may the 12th
i'll be 63 years old and i'm still here
you see 48 years later
once i left pasadena i never went back
to my family
i've been down here ever since so
everybody didn't know where i was
how was your childhood oh in my
childhood i remember a lot of things
that
haunted me all my life which is
my uncle one day was babysitting me for
my mom because she was at work
and he had fill up the bathtub with
water
and soak water bath water
bath soap and he was naked and he had me
in there naked
and he had me sitting on top of him
and and my mom she told me she almost
blew his brains out
her own brother when she walked in and
seen
him have me on naked on his lap
and she she put out a gun and she told
me
but she hated me ever since what she
seen
she hated me ever since she hated you
she hated me
and for what happened to me because she
he never ever got to know who i really
was because i was afraid
so i had many personalities from her mom
and at the age of six she was drunk and
she said you know what
i hate you i hate you or with a
passion you s some of it and all this
and things
she touched me she said and i asked her
why i was six years old i said why you
hate me mom
she said because of your father i hated
that [ __ ] for all that he done
to me
beat me in my stomach so i couldn't have
you
and all this this stuff and and ever
since
ever since the childhood i've been alone
i've been here for
48 years now your dad i never seen him
you would hit he hit your mom in the
stomach yeah so she can have a
miscarriage
when she was carrying you yeah she was
pregnant with me
but she what happened when he hit me her
hair and her stomach
it turned me around so when
she was giving birth one of my leg was
stuck
inside they pulled me out backwards by
my leg
and this leg was inside so what they so
they want me to drown
in my mouth they had to cut my a
vagina wide enough to take my pudding
leg out
so ever since my uh then my mom always
said
you know you've been a hell of a problem
uh
to me ever since you was born
so in other words she every like
she had to cut it open and get me out my
father beat me
reading her and her stomach so and you
know
so she hated him so she hated me because
she said you know what
you look just like that my brother
you're like just twin
and you talk like him and i hate that
number so i hate you too when i was six
years old
and these things see now i'm
diagnosed paranoid schizophrenia
failing bipolar and uh
all kinds of things because of my
lifestyle in
downtown here for 48 years it it
did it did a hell of a toll on me but it
may it didn't make me never make me
weak it made me stronger because for 48
years
it takes a hell of a person to survive
down the air like this for 48 years yeah
are you living on the street yes in on
these freeways
in parks in alleys in abandoned
buildings
wherever driving car wherever i can
are drugs a part of your life yes it is
uh
when i came down here i have never used
drugs in my life so
not even marijuana so when i got to down
here i met some people
and we made friends they taught me how
to smoke marijuana
then they told me how it taught me how
to smoke crack cocaine
and and that's that's enough in in spice
somebody had to show me how to do these
things because i never knew it
and what is your drug today my drug is
spice spice
yeah what does spice do for you spice uh
for me
it slows slows my thinking down
it slows my thinking down to to a point
where
i can understand
whatever my mind is trying to make me
understand
i i can figure it out and this is what
i've been doing for 48
48 years i've been figuring people out
because of so many different
personalities so many different
tragedies happened in front of my eye
i was standing closely for me and you
and this dude put out a 357 mag
put it to the uh juice head
blew this whole top of his head off his
brain fragments
splattered all over just all over the
sidewalk
they were still flopping because of the
nerves
blood and watertown out of the top of
his head
and and i and this thing made me suffer
ptsd you know now
i take a lot of medication in in my
apartment
now i thank god i'm not living on the
street anymore
for three years god has blessed me with
a brand new apartment
so i got a regular property now you got
housing now yeah how long has that been
three years three years yeah good for
you and uh
but i get my rent paid automatically i
don't have to worry about
not having the money to pay rent they
pay my rent for me
i'm on the money management so they
issue me
certain allowances out but they keep
keep my money for me that's nice and
it's been over three years they've been
doing this for
your children never have you ever been
married no
have you ever been in love no
do you feel like you were ever loved as
a child
so you've never you've never i never uh
knew how
love supposed to feel so when somebody
told me
one girl told me i have never had no sex
since 48 years now with a with a female
never have sex for 48 years why because
i met one girl when i was 17 and
i was in y.a california youth authority
they took to the hospital
she was a secretary so we got to meet
and she said
oh david after three days we know each
other
i love you you're the only man in my
life
and she she led me to believe this so i
gave
all my heart to her because not knowing
getting better i gave my heart to her
then later on down the relationship
she said uh well i can't see you
anymore i said what you talking about i
thought you say you love me
no i'm in love with i got married and
she showed me peter her her husband
i said you know and it broke my you did
something mentally to me
she was married yeah it did some memory
to me
just as well as uh broke my heart so
i never i never trusted women in since
48 years now i don't feel like i'm gay
or anything i don't have
no feeling it's not i don't know how to
feel
you know everything i went through i
i had to feel now i don't want to feel
would you would you call yourself would
you consider yourself happy
yeah yeah in a way because uh it's just
because of
the fact that i know i'm in contact with
god above
and he's been protecting me every since
48 years
i said yes yes my belief
helps me overcome a lot of things
because i believe that guys don't make a
way for me
to to make everything all right so i
just they
broke through the emotions go through
the episode but i know i'm not going
through it alone
he's going through it with me and that
makes me happy
that yeah so i consider myself blessed
less is this the best time of your life
right now
yes yeah as i grow old
as i grow this is the best time when i
look in the mirror now
see gray hairs in my hair here and i say
damn david
i mean when you had all black hair and i
be talking about stuff while you're
looking for me
but i said it takes wisdom and knowledge
to have that [ __ ] up there anyway
so obviously i've been through turning
my hair anyway
how old do you know uh 62 i'll be 63 and
mate
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
well promotion not to judge
not the judge no not to judge no one
and never uh turn your eye
on a blind eye when the person in need
are need of your of your advice or
something
i get stopped live and i tell people how
to change the lifestyle
of my experience i i have went through
another i say you know what
they say how do you get an apartment
come on i take them to the
step i said you got to go through these
steps now
now if you ain't willing to you ain't
gonna get no apartment and some of them
never
get an apartment because they don't want
to obey your steps
but i had to obey a lot of stuff that we
have an apartment that i got now
what's your view of your of the
childhood that you had your dad was out
of your life your mom was
well do you regret yeah the parents that
you did yeah
yes i regret everything they did to me
but i forgive them at the same time you
know
on my last mom died on her death bed
in the homeless hospital zombie some
somebody
in the drug program i was there found
out where my mom was
and they took they took me over there to
see my mom
i only seen her for seven days and she
died
she had alzheimer's she don't even know
who i was anyway
but i just was able to see her after 48
years
i see my mom when she was young and big
and healthy
now she's frail red hair and balled up
no i told him not to hate my mama no
that ain't woman i couldn't believe that
was my mother
you see 48 years almost 48 years changed
the person
and sometimes when i be telling these
stories i'll be crying
but i'll be crying from the inside
you never see a tear drop but for this
i've been crying all my life
i've been crying all my life but god's
been crying with me
i've been crying all my life and i tell
everybody that
they say you seem so happy that you just
if you only knew
if you only knew if you only knew it i'm
not happy
do you feel like all the things you've
been through have helped make you
stronger
yes the abuse made me stronger the
neglect made me stronger
the lack of love made me stronger
the the the kindness made me stronger
you know everything made me stronger
god made it right for me everything
right for me
what emotions do you deal with do you
get depressed sometimes or
no i i try not to get depressed
i i go walking or something or recycling
i i don't like uh to feel the pressure
no i take
i take right now hypertension pills for
pro depression
so you've had depression in the past
yeah
the medication helped you yeah
what was your favorite memory
to tell you too i don't have one
i was trying to think a woman i can't
no i i can't i don't know
oh okay i found out one
when i i went and purchased me a little
duck
so i had my little duck in my apartment
living in the bathroom he's he's pooping
every day where
i'm like oh hell no i can't even walk in
my bed without stepping
so i but i raised him from a little
chick all the way to like this
a big big duck so i mean he was like a
dog
he was like a dog come here come here
and he'll look at it and say come here
come here and he'll look he'll he'll go
he'll come to me he'll stay right by my
name
and nibble on my family but he'll come
to me
i had it for a month but my therapist
my psychiatrist told me david
well let let's take him to a shelter i
said take him from the center no
for what because uh he's getting too big
he's too big
and your apartment's too small for him
to run around he needs
uh a space so i i didn't let her
talk me into taking to a shelter
so that was one of my joyful time
being able to watch him grow and talk to
him
and he respond you know
given the life that you've had do you
what do you feel like life is unfair
well i don't know if it's fair or unfair
i don't know
i don't have to answer if it's very
unfair i just know life is
life life is life life is what it
is you can't change it
so why i try to figure it out just go
along with life and just
you'll be better off
all right david thank you so much for
sharing your story oh you're welcome
thank you man for having me yeah very
interesting
yeah thank you very much and see in
everything i told you
it's from my heart a lot of secrets i
hope
i'll let certain people know but the
ones who
don't need to know they'll never know
but i'll let you know
what what what i'm all about thank you
very much